thank you
look at that
that is very kind of you
you are
very happy for people who just lost a
war
well we lost another one
20 years in afghanistan oh my god first
they kicked britain out right then
russia
now the united states
if you're keeping a score the graveyard
of empires three empires none
man this country collapsed faster than a
condominium in miami
we're owing already
like a minute into the show
no it's a heart-wrenching scene i mean
you saw there's people clinging to the
wing of the plane i mean you know you're
desperate when you're doing that
who's thinking you know this could work
i saw tom cruise do it in mission
impossible
that's
but i mean and besides the loss of life
you know what this war cost
2.26 trillion dollars they say do you
know how many billionaires we could have
sent into space for that kind of money
but honestly
i feel bad for biden
because for years
the democrats the liberals were like we
got to get out of there
got to get out of afghanistan and then
trump comes in off and he's like we're
getting out i think we should get out
too he made the deal
so biden gets in office he's like well
everybody seems to agree on this one
let's get out [ __ ] you monster
i want your resignation tomorrow
trump trump wanted to meet the taliban
at camp david
that's true say what you want about
obama's birthday party the taliban
wasn't there
wow
they say trump is very frustrated about
this he says if i could just get on
twitter i know i could make this worse
you can't make it worse
it's getting it worse than the taliban
they forbid music
well music for pleasure you can still
play billy eilish
it's a battle between the growners and
the clappers tonight
clappers you've got to punch the
growners that's right
[Music]
no the
the taliban want to shut down schools
they want to shut down bars theaters
oh wait that's california i'm sorry
oh i i see you with the masks and of
course we're all safe here uh no they're
talking now about boosters that people
need boosters johnson and johnson says
this time they're really going to try
they said the last one was just baby
shampoo and aloe but we can do better
and of course
the big issue now kids going back to
school whether kids should wear masks
when they go back to school uh in
florida they have a you know they have a
rule against it you can't even try that
that desantis guy in florida ooh he's
hardcore but he doesn't like masks today
he was demanding to know why the weeknd
can't feel his face
and finally
i must end on
sad news tonight only fans uh is banning
somebody here today because obviously
they don't work we're in the afternoon
uh
only fans is banning sexually explicit
videos on their platform which is pretty
much what only fans is
uh i feel bad for the women of only fans
uh because since the pandemic hit
they're the only workers in america who
are still shaving
you